alors justement guillaume tabard ce
matin dans le figaro dit que précisément
le la
l'évolution avec la pma ouvert pour tout
c'est que on est on est plus dans une
évolution dans un changement qui
conduira inéluctablement à la gpa qu'est
ce que vous en pensez mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est me parlez de votre
ville tout à l'heure l'histoire de du
peuple de droite et celle d'un immense
et permanent cocufiage puisque les
dirigeants de droite passent leur temps
à se renier a trompé en fait les gens
qui leur ont fait confiance puisque les
personnes qu'on vient de voir gérard
larcher mais aussi on pourrait citer
valérie pécresse jean françois copé
était à la manif pour tous au premier
rang il se montrait d'avoir un caméra et
sur ces questions là vous continuez à
nous poser vos questions à donner on les
a vu rogner voilà progressivement leur
mission et en fait on a vraiment le
sentiment d'une droite qui à la remorque
de la gauche et qui finalement ne fait
que fait qu'avoir un train dans un train
de retard ça qu'une fois que les manifs
on le mariage pour tous est votée deux
ans après on dit qu'on est con et tu es
con et pour la pma et c est donc il ya
ce sentiment de le sentiment d'une
spirale inéluctable et d'une droite qui
finalement n'est qu'une gauche plus
lente et qui finalement ne fait que est
arrivé un peu plus tard sans avoir de
véritables convictions ancrées et
permanente et c'est assez catastrophique
je pense pour l'image que se font les
gens à pop après on peut dire que c'est
compliqué on peut dire qu'on ne sera
difficile de revenir dessus mais de dire
qu'on a changé d'avis et qu'on change la
vie parce que c'est une évolution
inéluctable
c'est quand même assez dangereux et
comment les gens peuvent croire ensuite
qu'on va dire non l'âge et perdre
puisque ces gens là ces gens qui
m'aiment gens là qui disent on est
contre la jcat aujourd'hui disait qu'ils
étaient contre la paix est manière dont
quelle crédibilité